[Musique]
la FRCA le département de La Réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la Réunion vous
présente terre
[Musique]
d'ici écoute la
brise écoute son romance
oublie la
[Musique]
peur les pieds sur terre la tête dans
les nuages de ces interprétations
musicales jean-jul Morel est un
agriculteur et un trouadour de facettes
de sa personnalité qu'il cultive l'une
et l'autre avec passion il faut dire en
effet qu'il a de qui
tenir
mes parents mes grands-parents ils ont
tous ils ont tous été plus ou moins
agriculteurs je dis bien plus ou moins
parce que mon arrière grand-père faisait
plutôt de l'accueillette je dirais
arrière grand-père mon grand-père était
moitié musicien moitié agricultur je dis
bien moitié parce que c'était des
orchestres en cuivre à l'époque ils
allaient faire des des balles j'allais
dire des beau mais c'est des balles ils
allaient faire des balles partout à
droite et à gauche et et souvent la
passion de la musique prait plus le
dessus par rapport à à l'activité
agricole proprement dit et voilà ce
n'était pas une agriculture qui était
rationnelle et conventionnelle comme
elle est aujourd'hui de père en fils le
travail de la terre s'est ainsi transmis
dans la famille Morel au fil des
générations par nécessité au départ et
puis aussi par passion sur leur
exploitation situé dans les haaux de
Saint-Joseph Jean-Jules Marie reen son
épouse et rodolp leur fils produisent
aujourd'hui dans des conditions
optimales sous ser des tomates de
qualité produit essentiellement la de la
tomateon de la grosse tomate sur
l'exploitation c'est c'est une on se
trouve à une altitude qui est qui est
bonne on est à 550 m d'altitude c'est
une altitude qui convient et pour la
petite et pour la grosse on on est bien
on est bien placé quoi tradition et
innovation sont les deux moteurs de
cette exploitation familiale Jean-Jules
est l'un des premiers par exemple à
avoir utiliser sur ces cultures une
technique de lutte biologique contre
l'alerode un ravageur de la tomate
une méthode mise au point par le cade
aujourd'hui encore la coopérative dont
il fait partie travaille en partenariat
avec d'autres acteurs sur un projet
innovant
d'écoextraction par exemple on va on va
accueillir une une aubergine on va la
manger mais peut-être que demain on
pourra extraire des molécules de cette
aubergine là qui auront une une une
plusvalue beaucoup plus importante
qu'elle a aujourd'hui et c'est ça
préfigure de ce que demain sera
l'agriculture dans dans le paysage
agricole de lîle si tu n'avances pas
avec avec l'innovation avec la technique
tu es en retrait tu n'es plus dedans
c'est c'est évident que chacun doit doit
avancer par rapport à ce que mes ancêtes
ont fait ce que je fais ce que mon fils
va faire ce que son petit-fils va faire
c'est une perpétu à évolution il y a pas
il y a même pas à discuter de
[Musique]
ça
à 22 ans rodolp Morel est en cours
d'installation tout jeune déjà il
voulait suivre les traces de ses parents
et devenir comme eux agriculteur depuis
là 4 ans l'âge 4 ans il va être
agriculteur il a travaillé à l'école
parce que pour agriculteur il faut
savoir lire écrire et c'est ça qui l'a
motivé pour l'école on é tiul
aujourd'hui d'un BTS agricole donc il
nous donne la capacité pour reprendre
une exploitation et donc nous installer
avec avec les aides si aujourd'hui est
important aussi d'avoir un niveau de
qualification pour pouvoir avoir des
notions de gestion de comptabilité parce
queaujourd'hui le métier d'agriculture
c'est pas seulement de de de grater la
pioche comme on dit c'est aussi la
gestion d'une entreprise donc c'est
c'est important je dis je pense sur
l'exploitation familiale Rodolphe a déjà
pris en main une partie de la production
légumière ainsi que l'élevage des
poulets et collé dans sa tâche par ses
parents bien sûr mais aussi par sa
future épouse
Émilie c'est plus facile come on sait
comment on travaille l'un et l'autre on
sait ce qu'on peut faire ce qu'on est
capable de faire donc on arrive à bien
se répartir les tâches le travail le
plus dur il fait moi je-être plus être
dans les papiers après je vais l'aider
dans les seres pour nettoyer ce que je
peux faire et puis lui le gros gros gros
c'est plus facile qu'être toute seule
chacun des trucs que chacun maîtrise pas
tout quoi ici comme ailleurs sans doute
c'est cette structure familiale bien
ancrée qui fait la force de cette
exploitation agricole ah bien sûr c'est
évident que le le fait d'avoir la
famille autour de soi les
parents les grands-parents par par le
par le le savoirfaire qui était transmis
par l'héritage et les enfants qui
reviennent dessus derrière et le et le
futur petit qui vient après c'est
évident que ça donne beaucoup plus de
force à une structure agricole mais je
dirais une structure agricole mais c'est
je pense que c'est aussi valable pour
structure économique quelle qu'elle soit
dans n'importe quel secteur d'activité
dire que la famille reste un pilier fort
important ah fondamentalement oui j'en
suis persuadé absolument une véritable
philosophie une autre vision de
l'agriculture que jean-jul et Marie
reenn aiment aussi partager avec les
visiteurs de leur git à Grand Coude ça
m'a paru toujours évident
que le monde agricole devait communiquer
avec l'extérieur et quoi de mieux queune
structure comme ça pour pour dire aux
gens pour montrer aux gens ce qu'on fait
bon j'ai la chance de pouvoir faire un
peu de musique et et de donner un peu
plus d'âme à ce que je fais mais c'est
vrai que chaque fois que les gens
viennent ici je peux leur expliquer mon
métier concilier le consommateur avec le
producteur c'est c'est je peux pas
expliquer pourquoi c'est arrivé comme ça
mais c'était un peu iné quoi de d'allier
le le métier de gitur de gitur de table
d'ôte et et l'agriculture en général ça
ça me paraissait quelque chose de
complètement de complètement naturel et
de complètement complémentaire les un
les uns par rapportxut
Alvarez toutes sans
histoir
malbar sans
[Musique]
histoire
e